a special essay for cbs mornings from
award-winning filmmaker ken burns it was
made on his with his digital website um
burns
new long-awaited project
on boxing icon muhammad ali is set to
debut this weekend the four-part
documentary series looks at ali's life
career and social impact to understand
ali byrne says we need to go back
further back into history to jackie
robinson in his struggle for equality
[Music]
i am proud of my blackness
proud of the accomplishments of black
people
[Music]
think of me as the kind of negro who
comes to the conclusion that he isn't
going to beg for anything
[Music]
that he will be reasonable
but he damned well is tired of being
patient
jackie robinson
[Music]
when i made my series on baseball i told
people it was the sequel to our civil
war series and they looked at me like i
was nuts
but if you want to know what happens
after the civil war the most important
event in our country's history baseball
is part of that story let's remember
that the first real progress in civil
rights since the civil war happened not
at a lunch counter in north carolina not
on a city bus in montgomery alabama not
in a school in topeka kansas but on a
baseball diamond in brooklyn new york
when on april 15 1947 jack roosevelt
robinson the grandson of a slave made
his way to first base
sports are an important mirror of who we
are and when i look at where we've been
two athletes stand out to me
jackie robinson and muhammad ali two
barrier-breaking black athletes whose
words and deeds changed the country and
proved every bit as meaningful as their
achievements on the field and in the
ring
[Music]
more than anything else
what african-americans have wanted from
america is a seat at the table
jackie robinson knew once he got in the
door
you could knock down all of these
conventions
first you get out there and you prove
you can play
then you can start talking back to umps
then you start dealing with
writers on your terms instead of their
terms then you start fighting to make
sure the hotels are integrated
[Music]
and over time
jackie robinson has pushed us forward
for him there was no satisfaction with
simply being allowed to enter the room
jackie robinson reimagined what was
possible he signaled the beginning of a
new fight for freedom
and 20 years later heavyweight champion
muhammad ali risked his career and
freedom to do the same
he stood on the foundation robinson had
laid and his refusal to compromise on
his beliefs and his willingness to
sacrifice everything for those beliefs
was another step as athletes help lead
the fight
for justice well whatever the punishment
whatever the persecution is for standing
up for my religious beliefs even if it
means facing machine gun for that day i
will face it before denouncing elijah
muhammad and the religion of islam i'm
ready to die
when i think about him saying
if they want to put me before a firing
squad tomorrow i'm ready to die before i
abandon my religion
um
that's it
[Music]
you can't teach that kind of thing in
lectures in books that kind of thing has
to be modeled
and models turn into traditions and
traditions provide people
with the mechanical memory to do the
right thing
the force of robinson and ali's examples
resonates as deeply in our current
moment as it did in theirs once again we
see athletes expanding on the tradition
of meaningful protests set by these
pioneering figures
in my films i always look to explore
subjects that reveal something telling
and crucial about the american story and
for me
sports can serve as a kind of x-ray
of the health of the united states it's
where we get a unique and raw sense of
where we are as a country
wow incredible piece um tony you know
this there's something about athletes
that gives us a confidence even a
stubbornness that makes us believe that
we're the best at the sport that we are
playing those same characteristics
they're qualities that we use when we're
standing for things that we believe in
which is why sports and social justice
are synonymous yeah well i knew darn
well i wasn't the best at basically but
i do know ken burns is the best at
documentary yeah pretty good track
record uh i think muhammad ali is going
to be another good one yeah i can't wait
to see it i love that he was so young at
the time and that was such a courageous
decision he was so vilified but he's
turned out to be on the right side of
history it seems the four part series
muhammad ali kicks off this sunday night
on pbs i can't wait to watch that